[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Keep the applause going.
Scott Hutchison.
[APPLAUSE]
We're full of them.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: You
guys have three mics.
That's amazing.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Unlike many places
where you've been spending
your time lately, I'm sure.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: No, yeah.
We usually just use one.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
So you touched on it
a little bit as you played,
but these songs are old.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah, they are.
Well, yeah.
They're mostly-- the album came
out 10 years ago this spring,
and the songs are older
than that, you know?
So they're just getting ready
to go high school, I suppose,
these songs, you know?
It's funny.
Well, because it's funny.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Spending
some time in the basement.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Spending
time in that basement, yeah.
But it's like funny when
my songs about fucking
are getting ready to
go fuck themselves.
[LAUGHS]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Is it strange to be
revisiting this material now?
Though I'm sure everybody knows,
but for those who don't know,
the tour is the 10th anniversary
of "The Midnight Organ Fight."
SCOTT HUTCHISON: It is, yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
How is it for you
to be, at a 10-year marker
point, revisiting this album?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: It's--
I mean, there's a lot of
stuff that I had either
forgotten or blanked out from
the time when we were first--
the main thing that strikes
me is not so much the content.
The content is what it is.
And emotionally,
in 10 years, one
would have hoped to have
moved on, and I have.
It's OK.
It's cool.
But it's just
thinking about the--
being that I'm 36, when we
were touring obviously--
26, 27-- even just
then, how much more
I could get away with, like,
abusing my body on tour.
You know, it's--
I get kind of pissy if we do
more than four shows in a row
now.
But I remember doing--
we would happily do like 12,
13, 14 shows without a day off
and stuff, and nobody cared.
It was just like we were
so full of excitement.
This album snowballed
for us that year.
And one of the reasons why
I have such affection for it
is essentially we got
back off that tour
and I didn't have
to go get a job.
[LAUGHS]
It's as simple as
that, you know?
So, yeah.
It's I have a great deal
of affection for the album,
and hence why we
decided to roll it out.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well, and it seems
that a lot of other people
have a great deal of affection
for this album too.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: It's true.
It's true.
There's-- I mean, I would say
about 80% of the conversations
I have about our
music are still--
with fans of the band--
are still about that record.
A friend of mine who runs a
record shop said that's it's
our business card album.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
That makes sense.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
It's like, if you don't like
this, you're just not going to.
Don't bother.
So--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And
interestingly, you guys
announced that you're
going to go on tour
and perform the record.
And I saw that come
across the email
and was like, oh, that
was not that long ago.
10 years doesn't seem like--
SCOTT HUTCHISON: I know.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
--a big time.
But then I went to
look and get tickets
and they were all sold out.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
People are into it.
I don't know.
I think it's not just for us.
This tour, it's not selfish.
Because I was-- when
I was saying before,
I actually used to think
that this kind of thing
was pretty corny and sort
of some kind of obvious way
to make extra
money or something.
But what we did instead
was we kind of--
instead of completely
rinsing the concept,
we decided to play shows
that were approximately
the same size as we did
back then, hence why
it sold out so very quickly.
And lots of people
complained about it as well.
So there's a lot of
unhappy customers.
They might never come back
to a Frightened Rabbit show.
But you know what
the problem is?
Back in the day, I guess--
before, your audience had a
direct lane straight to you.
So it's not my fault that
all of this happened.
But they can contact me
and say, hey, dickhead.
Are you going to add
another show or what?
And it's like, there's
10 people in between me
and adding another show.
There's not-- I don't
have control over that,
but I'm the first call.
So, like, announcing these shows
and then selling out-- like,
some of them genuinely
within minutes.
I remember I was taking a train
ride and I was just, like--
I just opened Twitter to see
how the sales were going,
and then just this
volley of abuse
at me from people who
claim to love my band.
But it's like, yeah,
they don't like me now.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
What do you think--
I mean obviously, we have the
lens of time to look back.
And a lot of people have
reviewed the record, discussed
the importance of the record.
And obviously, you guys
recognize the importance,
to revisit it now for fans.
What do you think is
the connection that
brought so many people to
this particular record?
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
It's very much--
it's probably the
most open album
we've ever made
lyrically, thematically.
There's a great deal of
honesty on it, which I think
people always connect with.
The strange thing
about that, though,
is even though
that was a success
after we toured the album,
towards the end of that tour--
it was like a year
and a half, and I just
started to feel like I was on
stage complaining at people
or revealing too much.
And there's something
special about that naivete
that we had that created
something that wasn't
censored as such, you know?
Like you said, there's kind
of use of poetic structure
to kind of veil and romanticize
these occasionally pretty
painful times.
But it's laid out, you know?
And I think the other
thing is, I joke now
about it being a cold-hearted
commercial enterprise,
because heartbreak
never goes out of style.
So there's always going to
be some poor bastard who's
just been dumped.
And this record has
become a bit of an anthem
for the heartbroken, I suppose,
because I was at the time,
you know?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And you
were saying before that you
get a lot of those stories.
People will just come up
to you and start unloading.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: They do, yeah.
[CHUCKLING]
That was a dirty laugh.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
Unloading, come on.
[GROAN]
They do-- that's what I
thought he was getting at.
Sorry.
Let's get back on track.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Minds
out of the basement now.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Let's get back.
Yeah, I know.
They do.
And it's strange.
A friend of mine once said--
and this isn't unique to
our album or our band.
But because of the
consistency of the subject
matter within this
album, he said, people--
and it is usually
a breakup situation
where someone loses the person
that they loved the most,
and then there's me.
And for those two
weeks, I sort of--
it sounds creepy.
I sort of seep into
their lives, you know?
And for that reason,
I think a lot
of people, when they
come and talk to me
and share their memories
and what they associate
with that album,
kind of already feel
like they know me well enough
to say these really personal
things, and that's lovely.
But also, I had to take a little
step back from it at one point,
because it becomes
kind of draining.
And there's, like, a
responsibility there
that is difficult to
come to terms with.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: They've
heard your heavy story
through the songs and
they think, oh, well,
I'll share mine with you.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: We can
go through it together.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Well,
little do they know,
I'm totally fine by the time
they're talking to me, anyway.
Because it's all happened, like,
a couple of years in advance.
But, yeah.
But it's not a negative
thing for people to connect--
project their lives onto
something that I've made.
Yeah, I like it.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And the
other question that I had was,
as an artist, you've
not stopped working.
You've been very busy
over the past 10 years.
Frightened Rabbit put out "The
Painting of a Panic Attack."
That's the fifth studio
album, is that right?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah, yep.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Is
it strange to constantly
be presented with
the old, instead
of wanting to talk about the
new record, talk about even
the Owl John kind of artwork?
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
Yeah, so honestly, I
have to put myself in
the shoes of a music fan,
which I am as well,
where I think--
maybe you guys can agree
or disagree on this theory.
But I think the first record
you hear by your favorite band
generally tends to be
the one that remains
your favorite, that album.
It doesn't have to
be their first album.
It's like your entry
point into it, you know?
So going back to when
I was a teenager,
I definitely loved "Versus" more
than any other Pearl Jam album.
I don't listen to it anymore.
But it's like that's
where I came in.
And a lot people came
in at that point.
So that's why I think people--
and I can't complain about that.
At least they're
enjoying something
that I've done, even if they
hate the new ones, which
is fine as well.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
I don't think
anybody hates the new ones.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: OK.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: But
we can talk about it.
There does seem to be,
with "Painting" especially,
a massive progression in
how the music is produced.
I guess also on how you
guys wrote the record.
Why don't you talk a little
bit about that process
and the change from
10 years ago to now?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
I mean 10 years ago, we didn't
have any fancy equipment,
for one.
I was writing and
recording songs
onto a cassette four track.
The leap that I thought
we took sonically
between our first album and
"The Midnight Organ Fight"
now seems ridiculous to me.
Because I was like, oh,
this is really polished.
And I obviously had call to
listen back to the second album
recently to just
learn the songs again,
and it sounds crappy to me now.
But I remember thinking
it was super polished.
But I guess we have
been progressing.
But at the same
time, there's a lot
to be learned from, again,
that kind of naivety
of making that album.
There's something
very human in that.
And I think if you
remove that entirely,
then your music will lose out.
So I have definitely
taken some tips
from that 25-year-old version
of me to maybe try and tap
into that a little bit
more going forward.
Because I think things
can get overproduced,
and I think we've
been guilty of that.
So it would be nice to
just keep the mistakes in.
Don't erase them on
a computer, which
is all too often the case now.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well,
and that's a very interesting
comment to make.
So many people talk about
the rawness and the honesty
of the lyrical content.
But that is also then served
by the rawness and honesty
of the recording.
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
It matches, yeah.
I didn't really-- we didn't
really know what we were doing.
And there was no
expectation of an audience.
There was no--
I didn't really know how many
people were going to hear it.
So therefore, that allows
you to be much more bold
in your decisions.
There's always something--
now, making a record,
there's a much larger
group of people
in the back of your mind.
As much as you may
try and make an album
just for yourself
and for the band,
the audience is there a lot.
Your live experience is there.
It's like, oh, this
little whoa-oh bit's
going to kill live, you know?
And it's there.
Again, so the whole
process now is
trying to be a little
naive about how
you're making the music and not
censoring yourself too much.
And if a mistake sounds
good, well, maybe you
should keep it or do it again.
Because if you do it
twice, it's not a mistake.
That's how it works, right?
Just in life.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I
think it's the third time.
Third-- third time
is intentional.
So with "Painting" you
recorded big portions of that,
or produced big portions of
that here, right, in Brooklyn?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Some
of it was in Brooklyn.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: With Aaron?
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
Aaron Dessner used
to have a studio in Ditmas, and
he doesn't have that anymore.
But that was the room where they
recorded most of the records
up till the last one,
pretty much, the bulk of it.
And it's a tiny garage
at the back of his house.
But he just-- it's an
extension of his brain.
So when we got
there-- you know, we
were in a bigger,
fancier studio upstate,
near Woodstock, called
Dreamland, which is beautiful.
But we did try and kind
of rough it up a little
when we got to the
garage, as Aaron calls it.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: There
was a lot more difference
with "Painting of a Panic
Attack" than 10 years ago.
You wrote the album in a very
different way as well, right?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: It was remotely
written, really, because I
had moved to Los Angeles.
And for that reason--
so I'd always
relied very heavily, or
certainly for the last 10
years, had relied quite
heavily on my bandmate, Andy,
who is very, very proficient
in music software.
And he just recorded
all our demos.
And I didn't have to push
a single button, you know?
And then I moved to LA,
and I'm like, ah, shit,
I'm going to have
to figure this out.
So I started using
Logic, and that
introduced a whole new raft
of sound to me as well.
So I wasn't necessarily
sitting down,
as I did with-- almost all
of "The Midnight Organ Fight"
was sitting down with a guitar
in a room, writing like that.
That kind of went
out the window and I
wrote a lot more from
beginning with a loop
or electronic sound,
just because I
was excited by this new
world that had been opened up
within my laptop, you know?
So that was a progression.
And yeah, just the
back-and-forth collaboration
was--
well, things take two
days to come together,
because they got an email
there when they were asleep.
And then they send me back what
they've done, and I'm asleep.
And then it goes
back and forward,
and let's call the
whole thing off.
But no, it was a little
bit of a longer process.
But I think it doesn't matter
if the situation is better
or worse than the last record.
It just needs to be different.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Yeah, I was going
to ask if now, going
back and looking,
has the nostalgia
gotten to you as well?
Do you look back at those
earlier times with the band,
and think, man, it was
so different back then.
I opine for that past.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: I don't
pine for turning up
at a venue with my
pedals in a plastic bag.
I definitely don't
pine for that.
But our setup is
quite complex now.
Sometimes, that can be a pain.
And yeah, there was an innocence
to it that-- you know what?
It just naturally-- it goes.
Your music becomes a business.
Your band becomes a business.
It's hard to avoid that, if
you want to make a go of it.
So it does change.
I don't pine for it.
I mean, I'm able to do
this freely and focus
on nothing else.
And that's a privilege
that I definitely
don't take for granted.
No, it was fun.
It's just, like-- thinking
about it is just--
it exhausts me to
think about that time,
because it was ridiculous
what I could get away with.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: One of the
things that has also come along
with the new record
that is more different--
and I think it's also we're
in a different landscape,
as far as being musicians and
artists in the world today--
are some of the videos
that you guys have put out.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
And I'm curious
how involved in some
of that stuff you are.
Because they-- they're not
like a typical music video.
They're sort of
these micro vignettes
of interpretive storytelling.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And
I wonder how heavy-handed
your involvement in
that is, or if that's
something that is
done, and then you
get to experience
it as a viewer?
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
Our involvement,
and the reason why our
videos are done that way, as
in they're sort of a
narrative, is that we
don't want to be in them.
So we try-- it's like we
sort of pitch for people
to make little mini
movies to our songs.
Because I don't think anyone
gets into Frightened Rabbit
because they are
attracted to us.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
It's just a fact.
I'm all right with being
substance over style.
But no, the videos--
I actually much prefer that.
We have had to do a couple
of performance videos,
but I think generally they suck
and they're not interesting.
They don't say anything and
they don't take the song
into a new realm.
So I'd much rather have
someone else's story plonked
on the song, and then
that puts it into--
puts a new
perspective on things.
It's much more interesting.
But I don't really have anything
to do with them, particularly.
But I always prefer to see what
someone else's interpretation
of the music is.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Can you
talk about maybe a reaction
that you might have had from
seeing some of these videos,
like the video for "Sober"
or "Wish I was Sober?"
SCOTT HUTCHISON: "Sober,"
that was full on.
Yeah.
So a drunk lady having a
really bad time, and yeah.
No, I was sort of
struck by that.
That was more-- that was further
than I thought the song went.
I mean, the song
was kind of like--
it has depth.
But I don't think
it's distressing.
But yeah, I mean, it wasn't
my favorite video, actually.
But it happened.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I'm just
curious about the control
and letting that control go
and how other people interpret
what you're putting forward.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
That's actually
one-- I would call
that one of the greatest
pleasures of doing this work,
is not having-- once it's
out, it doesn't belong to us
or me anymore.
It's in the hands or the ears
or the brains of the listener.
And that's really exciting,
for your album to,
like, pinball around and
different interpretations.
And hopefully-- and again,
I ask people this a lot.
And oh, I could ask you now.
If you're listening
to-- it doesn't have
to be a Frightened Rabbit song.
But if you're
listening to a song,
are you playing a movie in
your head that involves you
or the person that's singing it?
So I would hope
that it's not me.
I don't want to be in
your movies, all right?
I'm not attractive enough
to be in your movies, OK?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: But
you're about to be--
you're currently
being in a movie
that's being made right now.
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
Well, it's appropriate
that I'm in that, because it's
a documentary about Frightened
Rabbit.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Right.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: So--
[LAUGHTER]
I couldn't avoid that one.
I guess I'm going to
have to be in that video.
No, I'm really
excited about that.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
There's probably
people who would volunteer to
play you in the documentary,
if you needed.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: That
would be awesome.
Actually, yeah, apparently
the cop from "Stranger Things"
is coming out to
the show tonight.
Maybe he could do it.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well,
I was also thinking--
I mean, we kind of
look a little similar.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: You
want to be in it too?
OK, fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
How-- this is
a guy who's following
you around with a camera
as you're going through this
retelling of a past story.
Does it ever reach a
point of just surrealness,
of what is happening
around me that I'm
no longer in control of-- this
life has come into itself?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
See, that's where you just
lose your mind with anxiety.
I think this band
has given me cause
to sort of practice
a lot more living
in the moment and acceptance
of that and mindfulness.
It's been hard and it
doesn't always work.
But if you do get
too caught up in it--
because it's not
real life, really.
I go back to real
life when I go home.
And I go out on tour
and succeed at that,
and I'm comfortable there.
And I'm happiest when
I'm performing, in a way.
And I go home and it's just
like, what the fuck do I do?
Who am I, as well?
You know, you live--
a lot of what I had to do was--
because I was-- when
this album first came
out, the one we
were talking about,
I was receiving a lot
of people's stories,
people's praise as well.
And that can just--
that can take you in a
bad direction, I think.
So I have to now almost--
there's a persona
that I've maybe
developed a little bit,
which stops me from being
too personally involved in it.
That's really important to
keep my own life for me.
So there's been
adjustments along the way,
and there's been proper
breakdowns as well.
It's not always been fun.
But I'm grateful that it's
caused me to seek out tools
to sort of mentally survive.
But it's a drain
sometimes, for sure.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: We do
want to leave plenty of time
for members of our
audience to ask questions.
So if you guys do
have questions,
make your way to a microphone.
While people are
getting set, I want
to ask you about the experience
so far of "The Midnight Organ
Fight" 10th anniversary tour.
You've got a couple of
shows under the belt.
There's a handful more going on.
Are you enjoying
yourself doing this?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: I am, yeah.
I said that it feels like
being the DJ at a really
weird wedding.
Like, everyone knows what
songs are coming next.
There's crying.
There's drinking.
I mean, that's weddings, right?
Yeah, because we're
playing the album in order.
Which to me, the structure
of an album and the running
order of an album
isn't necessarily
ideal for a live show either.
Those are two different
art forms, I think.
So I've been getting
used to having
big depressing dips in our set.
Which are kind of
difficult for me
to deal with, because
I like to keep
things exciting and upbeat.
So that's been an adjustment.
But I am really enjoying it.
And I hope that
everyone that comes
is also getting a
kick out of it too.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well, and I was curious,
a couple of years
from now will be
then the 10th anniversary of
"The Winter of Mixed Drinks."
SCOTT HUTCHISON: I don't
like that record, no.
No, we're good.
We're good on that one.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Let's take a question
from the audience over here.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So a silly question--
I've noticed a lot of
musicians move to LA.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Have you noticed that?
And why did you move to LA?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Well, if they
did, I didn't meet any of them.
Because I had no
friends out there.
Actually, I kind
of got my wife--
I moved there because my
girlfriend lived there
at the time.
And that was the only
reason I had to be there.
It's a good reason,
but I didn't have
any ambitions to work in the
world that exists out there.
Because I didn't really
find a very coherent music
scene that I could
step into particularly.
It's all very disparate there--
a lot of closed doors, I think.
So the one place
I found solace was
in the form of a
small theater called
Largo in West
Hollywood, which is run
by an Irishman named Flanny.
And it turns out,
lots of stand-up
comedians really like
Frightened Rabbit.
I think we're all depressed
at heart, you know?
So I ended up doing
some really great shows
with great comedians there.
And that was almost the only
kind of community I felt there.
So if there are musicians
who are listening or watching
this--
I mean, just don't move to LA.
[LAUGHTER]
It's weird.
It's so strange for
it to be-- it truly
is one of the most
creative places on earth,
because lots of cool
stuff gets made there.
But you don't feel
that within the city.
It's all happening behind
closed doors, and it's like--
I just didn't feel like there
was a creative hub that I
could get involved in there.
Or maybe just nobody liked me.
So, who knows?
But I didn't have a
terrible time there,
but it wasn't for
me, in the end.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: We'll
take another question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm so excited
you're here, because now I get
to talk about my heartbreak.
No, I'm just kidding.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Hey, no, no.
Let loose, come on.
AUDIENCE: No.
I'm cool.
I'm good.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: All right.
You're good now?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm great.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: 10 years,
we've been through stuff.
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
I'm really pleased.
AUDIENCE: I love this record.
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
All right, great.
That's the new one.
You don't hate it?
AUDIENCE: No, I think it's good.
I like all your records.
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
Awesome, thank you.
AUDIENCE: But I wanted to ask
you-- first, I was like, oh,
why did he move to LA?
But they already asked that.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So now I want
to ask, when is it time
to move on to the next record?
I mean, with bands that
have lots of studio albums,
it's hard to please
all the fans.
Because you go and everyone
is expecting to hear
their favorite
song or they don't.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when
is it time-- when
do you start feeling,
oh, maybe this
is something for the new album?
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
Oh, like, when do we
start writing that really?
Well, I think the beauty of a
relatively long touring cycle
is, by the end of that, you're
pretty sick of the material
that you just wrote.
And you're also noticing a lot
of the flaws in it and the ways
that you would like to
improve on that next time.
So that's handy.
And for us, it seems to take--
the timeline is, like,
finish a tour, do
nothing for, like, a month.
Decompress and try and
start living normally again.
And then we'll try
and find another thing
to do that isn't necessarily
Frightened Rabbit.
You have to have some distance.
Because you spend all your time
in the pockets of one another,
and just personally, you need
a break from those guys--
especially my little brother,
who plays drums, you know?
Anyone else fancy taking
a sibling on a tour
bus in front of the world?
I love the guy, but anyway--
yeah, so having
said that, I guess
this tour is our
in-between thing,
and we've already started
writing the next album.
We're taking a
different route with it,
in that we feel
like, at this point,
we're kind of ready to
self-produce a lot more.
So we've kind of
refurbished our studio
and we're going to do
it there and it's all
going to be much
more in our hands,
as opposed to bringing
in a producer.
Which, there's nothing
wrong with that.
But I think we just feel it's
time to let our own voice
go kind of
untrammeled, in a way.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Thank you,
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
I'm just kind of curious.
How did you guys decide
the name of your band?
Is there a story about it?
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
There is a story.
I was very shy as a child,
and that was a nickname
that my mom and dad gave to me.
You know when you go to
those-- when you're a kid
and you're going
to parties that--
your parents' friends'
parties, but their kids
aren't necessarily your friends.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
know what that means.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: I really
hated those events.
And I was just--
I was just very shy, and
that kind of comes across
as being anti-social.
But I would just kind
of sit in the corner,
like, with the frightened
rabbit look on my face
and not talk to anyone.
So I thought it would
be humorous to call
the band that I hoped to play
in front of a lot of people
after a social anxiety.
So that's where it comes from.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Let's
take a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Ah, he was first.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: OK.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hey, thanks
for being here.
So my question is
about the artwork
that you did for Michael
Pedersen-- is that how
you say his last name?
The oyster-- the poetry book.
How do you find the artwork that
you want to make out of a poem?
It seems like they're
very different mediums.
So how do you, like, draw
the essence out of it?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: They are.
And Michael's poems are often
quite sprawling and long,
and that is hard to
distill into one image.
But what I tended to do was--
because I really
think about poetry,
the way that it can be often
and quite studiously worked
through, I much prefer
hearing poems performed
and reading them quite
quickly and taking whatever
jumps out at me from that.
So I take that kind of tactic
with the artwork, where it was,
like, I would give it a
couple of runs through,
and then if an image
came, I would draw it.
And it was as simple as that.
Because I didn't want to have--
again, thinking
about videos and how
you distill a song into
a concept for film,
I didn't want it
to be too heavily--
the drawing should bring another
aspect to the poem, as opposed
to me just describing something
exactly as it is there.
So that was a challenge.
But luckily,
Michael is a friend,
and we've worked together
and known each other
for many years.
So it was a very lovely
collaborative thing.
And he liked all the
drawings, so they all got in.
It was great.
I hope to do his
next one as well.
It's a real pleasure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: See you, tonight.
SCOTT HUTCHISON:
All right, nice.
Yeah.
I forgot I was playing the show.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: We'll take
our final question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I just
wanted to thank you
for the music over the years.
I still remember
where I was when
I heard "Things"
for the first time
eight years ago at 1 o'clock
in the morning, writing code.
And it's the drone that
really hit me hard.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
curious, just what
are you listening to now that
you can't get out of your head?
Because I couldn't get you out
of my head for a long time.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Really?
Oh, wow, OK.
"Things" is my favorite
Frightened Rabbit song,
by the way.
AUDIENCE: Really?
SCOTT HUTCHISON: So we're
together on that one.
What am I listening to now?
I love-- because
I'm on tour, I love
kind of cyclical
modern classical stuff
like Max Richter and,
unfortunately, the late Johann
Johansson.
And that kind of is all I can--
in general, actually, that's--
because I analyze music
when I listen to it,
that kind of music is
sort of analysis-free.
And that's really,
really comforting to me.
So it's in that
kind of wheelhouse,
like Nils Frahm and all
those studious dudes.
They're kind of my
rock stars, actually.
I went to see Max
Richter "play" recently
and I was, like, taken aback.
He was at the merch
desk and stuff,
and I couldn't even bring
myself to go and say hi.
I was, like, all
starstruck and stuff.
So, yeah.
It's a very meditative
listen for me,
and that's really important, as
opposed to listening to a song
and either deconstructing
it because I think it sucks,
or being really jealous
because it's fucking awesome.
That's really hard.
That's something I need to
let go of a little bit more.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well, and I thank you.
Thank you for taking the
time to sit and talk with us
today in front of Google.
And everyone, Scott Hutchison.
SCOTT HUTCHISON: It
was great, thanks.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]